we dranking I work we're drinking our
are we started
what's up y'all so I'm sitting at work
writing my own business when I stumble
upon this insane article in BuzzFeed
calm 22 bizarre alcohol combinations
that actually taste amazing
I scrolled through I found some things
that made me a little skeptical so I
went out bought the ingredients now
aside to my coworker just to put them to
the test
the Internet is a wild place so I'm not
sure what combinations they're gonna
come up with I expect to taste something
I probably haven't tasted before it's
not just people this is the internet
which is a whole different slew of
people it smells okay
you said coke and beer yes it does smell
fun kind of smells like a watered-down
beer experience a looot this is not bad
at all I can see how someone likes this
if they don't like beer this is like the
starter pack I would have this after gym
after the gym yes that yours should I
was a bartender and someone came up to
me and said can I have a coke and beer I
would serve them in two separate glasses
I would never think to put them together
there are some rum in there and then we
have a drink oh this is gonna be good
this looks folly apple cider and caramel
vodka it sounds like a fall drink sounds
like something that Lauren Conrad would
drink
smells like bed back to me out super
holiday e Christmas Thanksgiving it
tastes like a gift shop this is
delightful cinnamon and mangos weird
though yeah put those things together no
I know this will have a good aftertaste
this is not bad either
yeah I like that it's so good I'm the
same for that last that last drop boom
that in a spice that hits the back of
your throat fast many of you drink it
the cinnamon goes like in the back of
your throat and then the mangoes like
here [ __ ] I am kind of into it I
probably would drink this but then
regret it after I drank it I used to
like honey whiskey and then I got too
drunk on honey whiskey and then I
stopped drinking honey whiskey I fully
feel like this is gonna be very good oh
you can taste it just by smelling you're
just like I'll just like set this
underneath my nose and just let it
walked up onto me
I think I like it you know it was like
the Harry Potter jelly beans then you
pick a bad one that just like doesn't
taste good but it still has like this
weird sweetness to it it kind of tastes
like that it tastes like punch you would
drink in college yeah I know exactly
what this smells like and I'm gonna see
if you agree with me okay I think it
smells like a tootsie roll like this one
is thick like this the viscosity is very
high see it tastes like an orange
creamsicle actually it kind of tastes
like a chocolate Tootsie Pop you know
what this would be good like if you turn
them into popsicles a hundred percent
right yes this is bizarre done right
this reminds me of Kenan and Kel this
one is pungent this is like if if Kenan
& Kel though just like went on a bender
I am a huge orange soda fan so I have
high hopes for this week I'm into that
you like it I don't think it's that bad
imagine these kids parties whoever's
coming up with this thing
their lips these feel like wild about
the butterscotch candy element like
that's weird because it took so much
sugar already you're just putting more
sugar in the sugar I never ordered this
but I might drink it the internet very
easily could have trolled us today it
could have been like what do you mean
you don't know about milk and light beer
I think we lucked out all these were
perfectly palatable Thank You internet
for introducing me to some crazy new
flavor combinations internet you didn't
really hit the mark with the mixology
here so I'm gonna need you to leave
better mixed drinks in the comments
below maybe I'll try them on soon keep
making weird cocktails keep getting
drunk don't know I didn't say that
that one well I mean get drunk if you're
above 21 and inappropriate I don't know
[Music]